あっはっはー
アフ鋭角のすごいなぁ完全にリンチ場みたいになってしまいましたが今日は肇社長です
チーム前
病み上がりです普通で陣地倒れてましたというわけで今日はですねああこれもが戦で二
匹犬です僕は今年おそらくこのかなり摂取したの三女の95%は炭酸水ですこれで全部
じゃないんだよ本当は何か
ウィルキンソン炭酸どれだけ飲んだが僕を楽しみにしようと思ってて
今年からデリケート山
れ均等さん私からブレイゾンタンタンのんで全部ゴミ袋で打ってどれだけ飲んだか
来年確かめようと思ったんですけどそれ込みと歓声がさんに媚びに捨てられたんですよ
誰かに今回を求め台本名阪と政治はマジでもうミリ村炭酸しか飲んでないからハンサン
水の味に関して私が詳しいです今回は割と根もがちな方ですよこれ取れ
-6
人と思ってぬぐい計算たんじゃねーよ票を振らず目ずに米を売らず北1周分でベルギー
にそのターンさんだけを見続けて炭酸水中毒になり貧血を起こし中と思いました
ちょっと本番のメンツ伺っている炭酸水に関してはもう本当にたぐい稀に見ぬ今すごい
するよさんマジ本当には研ぎ澄まされてるんで
炭酸水を当てていこうと思いますその半年間の僕の努力が試されるいません
まだこの4社に何かそうかしていきましょうまずはこちら
セブンイレブンの炭酸水ですまーたまぁになりますよ降れケーソンダンサー乗ってる時
たまにの
てたんですけどたんだろうねぇ
美味しいでショップっ
美味しい c
美味しいでスタイルアンダーでサークルkサンクスから出てバーン水でそちらアサヒ
サントリー
ua たびに鳩が出てロールターン制ですコンビニでしか売ってない炭酸水を準備した
んですけどた皆に感謝匂いのある奴しかなかったのだからどうしようもなかったためで
も香りだけなので放つログが食べ普通の炭酸水だと思います0秒4の風景ずんたんさん
強い食べたの魅力職人を取る伝説と信頼のブランドでございますはいてこの4歳でて
よっ所ひとまずあずみで
4つの属すると思いますただ率は下地女ならとしっかりアセスこうしたに覚えさせるの
が大事です
一代です
me
うわぁこれはちょっとわからないところがあるような顔して実は本当に分かっていない
パターンてさてどうコメントしようかな天距離とこう
強いからこんなた
ていると思います次セブンイレブンそのまま伸びる感先制いきます西アジアす
うわぁこれはちょっと待てよさっき度になるとほとんど味が同じじゃないのか俺では何
も違いがわからず何でどれ半年か乗ってきたのに何もわからない同署と
適当に流しておこうかな二重グレードたんだといけます
これ強く右端だけで排気ました全く女たちのパターンとりあえずアーって言っておき
ましょうああこれもなんか彼だ
あの水と自分でも何言ってるかわかんねーや一発そう
打ったよために具などの香るダークですねっ
バッハ
においてばっかて無乳のか gantz に行きましょうにおいていう観点は出しじゃ
ないすいただけます
甘いんだけどなんで炭酸水じゃないこれジュースねーっ
エロいこれほとんどああ
バリばいいじゃんってよねそんなにまずを通る炭素星バズー数ですこの時点でしかね
ありがとうございましたちょっと確率が上がってしまったのですがこの3つで今回お
ためしていこうと思います旅どっかローン
あっチームならせめて僕の味を当てていきますを待ってくれないようにしないとね
ような3つの方々同じくらいにしておきましたペアだった下駄箱
んじゃあどれでも1個渡してくださいこんなにも見えてません関係
あっこれらベチャッやるやんください l
kazoo 焦ってああああこれねこれね
味だけでこちらねこちらがたんだという僕は確実に当てていこうと前説あってはいき
ましょう
エラキャップ
これでもあの伝える欄ではない何かに飲んだくらいで台西4
おおよそつくんですけど
訴える版のあれではない1月言えばこれね口当たりの両極のは二月村山さんください
これ何の炭酸水変わってます
セブンイレブン
def
ん
逆にこれめちゃくちゃオフ待ってっ
たと浮いてくる